the scary part is that Herschel Walker
had a chance and he almost won I've been
saying now for months that Herschel
Walker never should have even had a shot
in a country that made sense with voters
with some connection to reality someone
like Herschel Walker never should have
even won the Republican nomination in
Georgia to be Senator never mind getting
49 of the vote roughly uh in the general
election in Georgia which is what
happened in the runoff and there's a
couple of good articles and one that I
want to highlight in particular that
makes this case Jack Holmes wrote a
couple days ago in Esquire Herschel
Walker lost but it's a very bad sign
that he had any chance at all there was
a shark in the pool and nobody got bit
but why were so many people cheering for
the shark in the pool and the article
makes points that are not all together
surprising but the point that we've been
making and that Jack Holmes makes is
that although it's a good thing that
Herschel Walker lost he barely did and
the fact that he almost became one of
100 senators in the United States is
certainly emblematic and indicative of a
much bigger and scarier problem in the
United States and uh in the article Jack
Holmes writes it feels almost
unnecessary at this point to run through
Herschel Walker's record as a national
political candidate he's running in
Georgia but said in a campaign speech he
lives in Texas etc etc but as you read
down the article
it explains the answer for a lot of
people to the question why make Herschel
Walker a senator seem to be that if
Walker wasn't elected those people
Democrats marxists you know who the hell
knows would control the Senate and by
the time that the election came up on
Tuesday that was no longer the issue
because we knew that at minimum
Democrats would have a 50-50 majority
with Kamala Harris as the tie-breaking
vote
um and so it became more about who gets
power and who do Republicans vote for
and what are the principles here and who
are the backers of this guy and when you
zoom out and you think about what
happened you realize that this was
really the worst of the worst of
Republican politics at this point in
time what do I mean by that well it's
basically at least three different
things number one
for many Republican voters
and for the GOP establishment the RNC
at the end of the day it's simply about
is there a Democrat that we can prevent
from winning somewhere it doesn't matter
who we put in place so the no Democrats
ever is a big part of this and later on
in this uh in this part of the show
we're actually going to look at a
republican who is saying it's not about
no Democrats no matter what it actually
does depend who the Republican is and
Mitt Romney is that guy we'll get to
that a little bit later so you've got
the the lesson War knocks the Democrat
we can't have that that's number one
number two you have the maganon Maga
split so it has to be acknowledged that
the other Factor here is that Herschel
Walker is sort of a Maga cult type
candidate and as we know from following
Trump in 2016 and 2020 and into 2022's
midterms through his endorsements and
now as a 2024 candidate it is a cult and
one of the things about the cult is when
the cult leader tells you this is the
guy in this particular case uh you
accept that you accept that and you
don't question it and Donald Trump said
this is the guy and it failed
fortunately but the magicalists accepted
it so that's another layer to this
you've got better than a Democrat no
matter what
cult candidate okay
and then you have
the third part of this which is the
voters more broadly and this goes beyond
cult or not cult but it's the general
problem in the United States of how
there really is no bar
there's no bar for
the majority of the Republican
electorate big picture now that doesn't
mean they'll literally vote for anyone
in a primary but Trump 2016 was
instructive of that why did Trump run as
a Republican and not as a Democrat he
really was at least Loosely speaking a
Democrat it seems most of his life
but it was because there is some
standard on the Democratic party side
it's not anyone can get the nomination
just if they come up with the right
things to say even if they completely
contradict 68 years of their lives as
did Trump on issues of religion and
abortion and other things the Republican
party has no such bar and so because of
that we saw that they were gullible
enough to go for it in 2016 and then it
was sort of a path dependence that got
them there in 2020 as well those are
really the three things that this is
about and as it applies to Herschel
Walker we're all glad he lost Herschel
Walker in the U.S Senate would be a
humiliation to this country and it would
be a humiliation in so many different
ways great we dodged the bullet and not
by very much I think it's important to
say under a hundred thousand votes if
I'm recalling correctly but
he had a shot and as we saw in 2016 with
Trump sometimes you don't Dodge the
bullet and then in 20 we did Dodge it
and so let's not take away there's
people emailing me saying
we made it we made it the 2022 midterms
they weren't as bad as they could have
been yes they weren't as bad as they
could have been but they were almost so
bad that they could be that bad or worse
in 2024 we don't want to allow that to
happen
our sponsor real paper makes toilet
paper 100 from bamboo never from trees
meaning no deforestation sustainability
and climate change can be a tricky topic
for people of all ages it can be
particularly challenging to talk about
with kids and real paper recently
launched the little lemurs box a 24 pack
of their bamboo toilet paper with a
beautifully Illustrated Kids book that
tells an exciting story of
sustainability the box is designed to
spark creativity and kids create an
opportunity to talk about deforestation
plastic pollution in a way that's light
and easy and with the holidays here the
book makes a great gift for a little one
on your list real papers little lemurs
box and all of the other products are
available in Easy hassle-free
subscriptions or just simple one-time
purchases on their website all orders
are conveniently delivered to your door
with free shipping and this is the best
part 100 recyclable plastic free
packaging go to realpaper.com
lemur and sign up for a subscription
using Code Pacman at checkout to get 30
off your first order and free shipping
the link is down below